nathan mirvold is one of those rare
individuals who it's difficult to
overstate the accomplishments of here is
just a small sample of a list of fields
that he's made extensive contributions
to
it's by no means exhaustive nuclear
power that is
the inventing of new reactor types one
that can use
uranium-238 and spent rods of other
nuclear reactors he also in his early
days founded microsoft research
which back then startup software
companies didn't have a research
component to them
this trend of apple research and google
research
they're just adam brations of his
original creation
he founded a company based solely on
inventing he thought well there is no
modern-day equivalent of edison people
just invent in their own specialized
field why not have a company of a team
of people like edison
he also invented new methods of modes of
delivery of treatments for malaria and
other infectious diseases under the bill
gates foundation he also came up with
geo-engineering solutions to the problem
of global warming
we were scheduled to talk for just under
an hour but it went far over two hours
and i didn't even get to half the
questions that i had written down
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with
nathan muirvold okay so why am i
interested in you
well i'm extremely interested in you
i've been following you for
we'll fix that yeah
i've been following you for about maybe
12 years
when i was an undergrad i remember
hearing about your book on modernist
cuisine and being fascinated and doing
plenty of research into you and thinking
that
there are few people very few people in
my life that i wish were my uncle
that i can
that i can persistently and bothersomely
ask questions too
and and so for years and years i've had
this fascination with you every once in
a while i'd check in on you
and i admire you you probably get this a
lot but i admire you i look up to you
there are very few people i say that
about and so even with this podcast
i don't give people introductions
because i like to just get right into
the meat of it but for you
i have to tell the audience about my
journey with you and some of your
accolades
so if you don't mind can i just get rid
of it okay
i'll try not to roll my eyes yeah yeah
i'm just gonna read some of this so this
this podcast is about theories of
everything and
it's also about publicizing some
intellectuals that i don't think get as
much credit
as they deserve now obviously you're
extremely successful
but i was watching your ted talk which i
think is superior
to the majority of ted talks that i see
and it
many ted talks have tens of millions of
views sometimes but yet yours only has
two hundred thousand
okay so if i can help that in any way
i would love to with this minor podcast
of mine
it doesn't seem like you need my help
you're effectively a billionaire and you
have
many scholarly accolades nathan mirvold
is someone who has
a variety of interests and
it just astounds me i don't know of
anyone else who has the same amount so i
decided why don't i just start
to list them and i don't think this is
exhaustive in the least i asked your
team
and even they couldn't come up with all
of them is there a list online well
anyway here's some so
dinosaur slash paleontologists you like
dinosaurs you love looking into paleo
you like
even digging okay great asteroids you
have an interest
in scanning the skies and analyzing the
data of nasa
yup nuclear power okay eradicating
malaria
meta materials quantum gravity in your
former days
software obviously microsoft food
modernist cuisine penguins okay i
thought it was just penguins apparently
it's more but i forgot what your team
told me
all kinds of birds and animals hungry
animals great great great
what am i missing
um well i do a lot of photography
right um so photography of
almost all of the things that you
mentioned photography of
stars and meteors and asteroids
photography
of landscapes in the natural world uh
photography of food
uh for the cookbooks so that's another
one
um uh you know
more generally math and
uh technology fascinate me science
so i think of you as a convivial and
quirky version of elon musk
a lesser known convivial and quirky elon
musk and i've
never had the fascination with elon
mainly because of perhaps personality
differences i'm more on the
theoretical end that's my my background
is in physics
and he's much more practical you seem to
have
both no for me like
i'm more comfortable with qft than i am
with bernoulli's equation like i for
some reason
i'm serious for some reason what's
practical in in the engineering side is
it's difficult for me to apprehend
nathan first of all how do you spend
your days
like what does your average day look
like if there's an average day how much
sleep do you get
what is the structure well you know
i don't think there's any single typical
day
um many of the things that i
do involve you know
very different activities uh today i had
some of the last meetings that
we'll have on um our pizza book
i just wrote a book called modernist
pizza yeah which is aiming to be the
definitive book on pizza
uh and so we had a few meetings to wrap
that up today and not probably a few
more but
it's we're getting down to the short
strokes we're almost done
um i had my picture taken for the book
um because you know it's
kind of goes to the territory i did a
bunch of work
on astro photography
um in december there was a really big
uh meteor shower a shower called the
geminids
and usually the the geminids at least in
my
experience every time i
remember to look to see about going to
see them
what happens is there's it's cloudy
or well the moon is up when the moon is
up you can't see as many of them
um well this year or i guess last year
the very end of 2020
everything came together and i took some
great pictures of the
geminids and now we have to process them
um and the way i do photography
these days is very computationally
intensive
right so in the case of these meteors
uh i took about two and a half thousand
pictures
per camera times four bit cameras so
it's about ten thousand pictures
over the course of one night while these
cameras tracked
a part of the sky and then
because you're tracking the sky the
stars are all nice little dots and those
look really nice
but the meteors come down to streaks
uh well there's all kinds of processing
that we have to do
to get uh
a usable picture out of all that stuff
um i mean so far the pictures
and then all of the temporary files that
you create as you
because sometimes you have to put it in
different formats for different pieces
of software
is 20 terabytes
20 terabytes for one night what will be
one image
ah uh-huh wow okay i'm very anxious to
see how that turned out
uh so how much sleep do you get on an
average day
um you know i've been through periods
where uh i'm traveling
or we're working on some big deadline
for something where i get very little
but usually i get
enough sleep i get eight nine hours of
sleep
the reason i'm asking is that i see you
as someone who's extremely productive
and when i speak to intellectuals i find
that they generally are regimented
that they eat a certain type of food at
a certain time of day
or they don't eat a certain type of food
at a certain time of day or they
meditate
or they take a certain nootropic
and i'm curious what is it that you do
such that you can accomplish all that
you accomplish
it's different each day well it is
different each day so
you know this today was a mix of
different things
um in
i guess the end of february early march
i'm gonna go to missouri i i built
a special camera outfit which looks
pretty ridiculous
it lashes three cameras together each
one of the giant lens
um and i did it so i could photograph
two things
one is big storm waves
so i want to take some super high
quality panoramas
of ocean waves uh and also
um huge flocks of birds
well in missouri they don't have any
storm waves but they do have
uh migrating uh geese so about two
million
of them are due the end of february so
when i go
there i'll probably be there for three
four days maybe a little bit longer
and that'll all be about that and i'll
um i went to see some other migrating
birds in december
or late i got late november actually
late november um
and that was about getting up at four
every day
um so that you could actually be out
where the birds are well before the sun
comes up
because that's like that's the whole
thing
um with the uh
the meteors uh the meteor shower
uh besides all of this technical
equipment that i brought
i also bring a lawn chair because
you want to sit outside and see them and
it's
it's cool to see them um our eyes aren't
good enough to see
all of them you see you want to get a
camera catches more
but a camera catches it from a narrow
thing whereas if you're out there you
see them across the whole sky which is
is quite remarkable so anyway different
projects will require you to jump in
with both feet
and be a hundred percent on that project
but most of the time
not and so that's what allows me to
multitask between projects
how do you choose what project are you
just driven by your
intuition your feelings your desires or
is there some grander plan
well
it's of course there's intuition
and feelings and if i don't want to do
it i'm not going to go do
it and i would hope that my
it's not just my raw passion
uh a lot of the things that i do
are technically difficult to do
so far they haven't been impossible
now i'd hate to pick an impossible one
and get passionate about it
because then you'd waste a lot of time
right
is there something that you found to be
outside of your domain of competence or
outside of what you can do
of course there's i mean problems like
nuclear power
um or there i was one of the inventors
of this new type of a
nuclear power plant i started the
company
that company is going great at the
moment it's
uh was recently chosen by the
us government to build some test
reactors
but i don't this is not
a one man or even one company thing
nuclear power
intrinsically also involves the decision
society makes
um of course one of the reasons we've
done it is because we want to have a new
type of carbon free
ener source of energy because of our
impending climate crisis
which is a crisis for everybody
um and uh it
there's a bunch of things that i i
so yes i'm working on the climate crisis
i've done other things for climate
but it's not like it's up to me okay not
like i have a magic wand
and i can school solve that problem i
can make it
that's when i make a contribution i try
and we'll see what the world does with
it
whereas if i um last year i
uh created a the world's highest
resolution microscope dedicated
to photographing snowflakes
i saw that now
there's a lot of things you could ask
like who cares or why
but that's one that was
within the scope of
what i thought was possible for me to do
that turned out to be a lot harder than
i thought it would be
but we got it done that's very different
than a societal problem like
eliminating malaria i've contributed i
think a tremendous amount towards that
fight
but it's a tremendous amount towards a
fight that's
you know this far along against
many miles to go so uh
and i i think it's important to work on
both kinds of things
you know you could say
the climate crisis or malaria is
tilting at windmills or doing things
that are
you know beyond anybody's single persons
ability and it's true they are
i to the degree you find a way to
contribute
i still want to work on them but it's
also nice to
do things like write a book on pizza
again i um
i've written a couple other cookbooks so
if you ask the question
is it possible for me to write a book on
pizza the answer is sure
that was not ever a question like will
will he write the book
um now you can the what's that question
is is it a good book is it not a good
book what does the rest of the world
think of it
um we're publishing it uh not only in
english but we will publish it in
italian
what will they think of it right
um so anyway it's of a very different
nature
than something where you don't know if
it's possible
a lot of people don't know that you did
your postdoc under stephen hawking in
quantum gravity
yeah what was that like how do you
practically speaking how do you
communicate to stephen hawking how does
that process work given
his challenges uh
well back in the day that i was with
stephen he didn't have a voice
synthesizer
you know if you've seen him on more
recent
uh tv specials or something he always
has a voice synthesizer he hadn't he
didn't have that
so he would speak as best he could
which didn't really sound like human
speech at all
um and uh
his it was slower what was it also
slower
well it was we'd have to it was slow
it was very very hard to understand and
so
understanding it was partially about
listening and partially about guessing
and the part that was really um
unfortunate about that is he loved to
tell jokes
well it turns out the punchline of a
joke by
definition isn't expected right right
right
you can't guess ahead beat the punchline
four and five
and look at the tension is growing with
everyone like oh my god why don't we
get we get this um so the thing about
working with stephen is uh it's very
hard to feel sorry for yourself
if you're working with stephen you know
you might get up and you think oh
god am i feeling that great and oh it's
cold outside and i forgot
you know this and that and the other
thing and i'm
oh my god my life sucks and then
you have stephen there who has these
incredible physical challenges
and has just an incredibly
good attitude about it
and so it just it made it impossible to
feel sorry for yourself
and it's to this day it's something that
when
i'm ever tempted to i was thinking yeah
but i can walk you know i can go to the
bathroom by myself
you know some people denigrate stephen
because he was heralded as the next
einstein at least in the popular media
but then it's a it might be a stretch to
say he was the next einstein
but what you can't fault him on at all
is his diligence his persistence
and the only other person i can compare
him to would be euler who was blind
and still did math but at least euler
had his hands
so um well
stephen was driven to do the work
that he wanted to do and it wasn't a
question of
oh we had to go do it because
you know he needed the salary because
you know the any of these other things
and
he certainly worked as hard as he could
you know
in you know through being 70.
um yeah and it obviously at different
times his
ability to work was compromised by his
condition
but he did incredible things
now the the problem with comparing
um to einstein
is that einstein
was a
unique combination of both brilliance
and he came at a time when he could
discover a tremendous amount of things
um you know if if you want to call
someone the next einstein
the first thing to ask is well who was
the is who was it before einstein
and you could make a case for it being
newton
but okay if you if you take those two
data points that means we should get one
every 500 years
so calm down on the
who's the next einstein um
there's a wonderful organization
uh created by a uh a friend who was
also at cambridge at one point not the
same time i was there
um and it was
the name the organization is next
einstein from africa
and their idea was let's improve
education
and so forth and my
my running joke with the guy who started
it is
okay but there's never been an einstein
from america
so you know america has more
phds in physics and has more nobel
prizes
than any other country and then if you
include
in america's column people from other
countries
that did their work they got the phd in
america
it's huge and yet you could make a
strong case that there's never been an
american
that had the breadth of contribution
that einstein did
now that doesn't mean we didn't have
some awesome physicists we did
fine uh um you know the feynman
is a terrific example
but einstein had the unique case that he
was able to make
very fundamental contributions in
multiple areas
you know we know him most in the
particular
popular realm for his theory of
relativity
amusingly that isn't what he got his
nobel prize for for
um he got something called the
photoelectric effect which was
uh one of the first great proofs of
quantum mechanics
which is weird because people usually
think of einstein as being anti-quantum
but the part i really love about it is
that max
planck who was the great physicist of
that era
wrote a recommendation letter for
einstein
to the um uh nobel prize committee
saying look don't effectively
don't worry about this relativity
nonsense it'll blow over
the kid is young you gotta reward him
for this other thing
interesting and yet today
uh we think of him for that but his
uh his role in statistical mechanics
with um what we now call boze statistics
uh it is also incredible
and you must keep going through field
after field where he
was able to be incredibly influential as
was um uh
newton um my favorite crazy newton story
is that uh you know he was made
the chancellor of the british mint
and at the time that was done
as a political favor and it was
explicitly a position that they would
uh call a sinicure meaning without care
like he didn't have to show up at the
office you know
he got into it okay and
if you have an american quarter
the edge is ripped the person who
invented that
sir isaac newton and the reason was
they had a problem with uh
many of the metals with the
the edge of the uh coin holding up there
was a
maintenance there's certainly a problem
of they couldn't make a clean edge
and then it would also wear and then it
was harder to tell
counterfeits so that milling and i
forget the name of it now but that
milling was invented by
newton so he did some now
he also did some crazy [ __ ] he was into
alchemy so his chemistry was terrible
have you thought much about what's
holding physics back
if you see physics as being held back in
the fundamental laws
for the past 40 years some people say
that it's been taken over by string
theory as well as we don't have
much of data when it comes to we don't
have much new data
so have you thought much about that oh
sure this is
this is the defining problem of our age
the
my joke with friends from graduate
school is that it all went to hell
uh as soon as i left physics um but
yeah you gotta go back man no it wasn't
i'll be with you every step of the way
i'm not the reason okay it was it was
either
good choice on my part or it was a
coincidence i don't think i could have
solved i think there's a causal arrow
yeah we have uh we've had the situation
where uh you know in the 19th century
they thought they were on the verge of
figuring everything out there was just a
few pesky problems
then in the early part of the 20th
century
up through the 20s and the 30s they
realized
they had no [ __ ] basically
and this led to
the development of quantum mechanics
well quantum mechanics was fantastically
successful
uh then it ran up against fundamental uh
physics and relativity so they had to
create
relativistic quantum mechanics and
quantum field theory
and all of that was
pretty much in place um i
i went to uh graduate school in physics
in 79 the fall of 79.
and while i was
there maybe the first year maybe it was
the second year
um a guy who had been a
graduate student who'd stayed on as
opposed to frank wilczak
gave a talk about asymptotic freedom
which was one of the last
pieces to really be put together as part
of
the story of quarks and
what people call quantum chromodynamics
or the standard model
uh and uh frankly got the name about
price for that
well you could pick other moments in
time but
for me that's a good moment in time
because at that point in time
we knew there were a
tremendous number of questions that we
couldn't answer
we had successfully integrated multiple
kinds
of uh fundamental physics so
we had successfully integrated
electromagnetism
with something called the weak theory
for the weak interaction it was an old
electro week theory
then we had developed quantum
chromodynamics
or qcd and together these things develop
what
since then we call the standard model of
course we didn't call it the standard
model when it was just
freshly done because it was a little
arrogant to call it standard
right off the bat but
and yet we didn't know a lot of very
basic things
we didn't know the
precise relationship between many of our
sets of particles um
leptons which means an electron or a
variety of other particles like that
what are their relationship to the
hadrons
the um
we didn't know the biggest ones we've
now had
all of that fit with gravity
um now by that time we knew that
the uh einstein's general theory of
gravitation
worked great and it predicted all kinds
of things
um still works great
and that's the problem the standard
model
works great in its
sphere of influence
jr works great for gravity
how the hell are they related and
they have to be related because there
are
many many things that
uh are clearly
truly involve both quantum mechanics and
um uh and gravity
my my favorite simple one is candle
flame
is what the candle flame okay light the
wick on the candle
it goes up as it go up gravity
it's heating the gases they become less
dense
it goes up that light
that light you're saying is quantum
emissions
there's clearly quantum phenomena going
on in a gravitational field
how are they related now that's a very
simple example and people could probably
sort of explain that or wave their hands
to explain it
but when you get to uh black holes
and and the intense things that space
time does around black holes
or you get to the origin of the universe
or a variety of other things you got a
problem
and so
people set out to solve that
and uh the quote theory of everything is
one of the names that people
gave to that pursuit uh there was a
time when people called it a grand
unified theory instead
but the goal even though the there was
slight differences in what you
would approach the goal was very similar
um so anyway that was
uh that was the situation
40 years ago and it's the situation
today
have you been keeping up with any of the
latest theories of everything such as
weinstein eric weinstein's geometric
unity or
stephen wolfram's yes
oh sure um
i i need to backtrack though there's one
other thing that is
remarkable about this last period of
time
um and uh that
goes a little bit to your question of
the whole world's attention was captured
by string theory well
it starting
with relativity so really starting in
1905 you could argue
but particularly then general relativity
and quantum field theory
an enormous amount of advances were made
by considering the mathematical
structure of the problem
and in particular the mathematical
symmetries of the problem
and that when you found a mathematical
symmetry
it would if you took that seriously that
would give you
new and important physics
so general relativity is in some sense
the theory of general covariance
so if you take einstein's extremely
simple set of
things of saying you know you you have
these relative observers
and um the inertial frames are the same
the accelerated ones and not so much
uh that gives you general covariance and
that gives you
general relativity and then those same
thoughts about applying covariance
uh give you a tremendous amount of what
it takes for a quantum field theory
you then also take the idea of
symmetries
and say hey we have mathematical
symmetries
are coming and that's uh murray gilman
was famous for calling this the eighth
fold way
because there's a
group theory with an eight-fold symmetry
that was involved
and so mathematics was a tremendous
guide
and when you found a mathematical
symmetry
it usually would have a physical
interpretation
well until we found a mathematical
symmetry called
supersymmetry and supersymmetry
from a fundamental mathematics
perspective
it's very attractive
and it has sucked an enormous amount of
brain power
into saying look this is so beautiful
it's got to be correct
only so far as we can tell it's not
correct
like it got normal energies meaning the
what we've been able to observe so far
with even our best
uh stuff even the um lhc
it predicts there should be twice as
many particles as there are
those those particles are called super
partners
and fundamentally if you have a
the super symmetry it's analogous to
saying
well if i've got a charge
you know minus one particles i better
have charge plus one particles
and so i have supercharges well then i
need super
partners so then
and this idea was so seductive
that people have
um gone
put enormous amounts of brain power into
trying to make it work
and the the big showdown that everyone
expected
was the lhc
and the stated purpose of the lhc
was to find the higgs boson
but
almost everyone expected
this would also be where we got the new
set of clues
and this is where we would be able to
solve this fundamental problem
because we've gone this 30 or 40 years
staring at the old clues
and not coming up with anything
and in general physics has progressed
best when we had clues
now general relativity is the great
exception to that
einstein's uh inspiration for that
is so
weak it's so
simple it it almost sounds
simple-minded you know like someone
coming into you and saying ah
i've got this guy in an elevator and
this guy is on this
and i'm going to tell you all about the
structure of the universe from this
you'd say
no no no no you're in that case
but not not not einstein so that was a
rare example of someone who had very few
clues
um uh newton
had very few clues you know that there's
an apocryphal story about the apple
falling and hitting him in the head
that guy did not take very much in the
way of
uh inspiration to get going
um so that was another great one but
we've we have this problem now that we
have the same clues we've looked at for
30 or 40 years
lhc found the higgs boson
um it didn't find any super partners
and so far it hasn't had any hint
of that and periodically
over the last three or four years there
will be a murmur
in the field of oh there's someone's got
you know
so and so in this to the two different
projects of this atlas
and alice oh alice is seeing something
or atlas is seeing something
um
but so far that's all come to naught
and it's probably true well certainly
given
that outcome
if you looked back at the field 20 years
ago or 25 years ago and said
okay we don't really know what's going
on
should we put all of our eggs in one
basket
you'd say no let's you know
we should bet on lots of different ideas
but
there was an overwhelming bat on super
symmetry
and string theory and
the weirder it got in going
chasing that direction down
it didn't dissuade people now there's
friends of mine who say oh nathan you're
out of it you don't understand how
wonderful and how beautiful it is
i i will stipulate to it being beautiful
um and string theory has
uh led to some interesting discoveries
mathematics
uh ed whitton who i've known since
graduate school is a
great friend and i think the world of ed
uh got the fields medal in mathematics
for a lot of things he worked on while
trying to
investigate super symmetry and string
theory
and string theory arguably has got a
physical result to its name and that
helps you calculate the modes in a black
hole
which uh go to the still somewhat
controversial
uh issue of whether a black hole
destroys entropy
but at this stage
we need one of two things to happen we
either need
new clues or we need
some damn genius who's so smart he or
she does not need clues
well those geniuses seem to come around
every 500 years
now maybe we got a little larger
population today and we're educating a
larger fraction of that population so
maybe it isn't 500 but
it's not a great uh it's not
not great statistics there um or
you need new clues but uh
lhc was ridiculously expensive
trying to come up with a something that
is
dramatically better than lhc
yeah they probably can eat
some number of factors and i i'm not
involved in it so i won't speculate as
to how many factors but
let's say they got a factor of 10.
um we don't know what the present will a
factor of 10
matter or will it be a factor
of 100 or will it be a factor of a
thousand or
or what right
and as a result
that very confused story
doesn't seem like it's the single best
story to go
take to nation states and say please
give us
500 billion dollars that it might take
to make something that was
many orders of magnitude better right
right or or we just say okay we have to
put on our thinking gaps
and come up with cheap ways or cheaper
ways
to get to that next level of power
that's also a possibility
but either way we either need
some genius on the old clues
or some new clues now there are people
who are
working on this um peter white who was
uh my roommate in graduate school
one of the most articulate critics of
string theory
um on his blog not even wrong
peter has recently come out with what
to me look like some very intriguing
ideas
and they're along a different approach
than most people have taken
in the past
but they're not done yet either they're
uh
they're a stab in the dark
and it will require a lot more work
um within the field of computing
there have been since the 1960s
there have been a variety of people who
have tried to take
the idea of computing as a metaphor
seriously
so um
there's a great uh essay which was
originally a lecture um
by uh edvard vigner
vigner was a nobel prize winner in uh
physics
and the name of this essay is the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics
in physics and so finger says look
how come it's so damn easy
you know we we a lot of physical laws
are first or second order equations
and most of it's linear which means we
could solve it
and then of course we know that there
are other parts of physics that aren't
linear but
the if i were to give a modern
version of wigner's thing
i would say hey not only has it been
math has had it it's a great
run but are we sure that it's
mathematics in the same way we've done
it before
that we need next and that's why people
like david deutsch as an example david
deutsch
is a physicist he was
the inventor of quantum computing if you
will he had the idea that maybe you
could compute
with quantum systems
and david has done some very deep
thinking about
what it would mean to have a computable
universe versus not
where instead of relying
on uh
simple equations with polynomials or
sines and cosines the things that we're
used to in
in school maybe the world is
fundamentally more about
computation and computation
is in some sense fundamentally more
complex
than that simple mathematics
and you can figure that out
in things like the various complexity
theories
that you know a simple touring machine
can't predict when it will end
just as a matter of principle it can't
yep well um
there's a whole pile of people besides
deutsch that have
gotten excited about this uh
but i've known stephen wolfram since i
was at princeton he was at the institute
for advanced study at the time and
he's a great friend of mine i have huge
respect for him
i use mathematica almost every day
is his great uh contribution uh
to software um he's got
a uh an approach where
he has been able to replicate
the classical this is perhaps slightly
unfair did but
he's able to replicate some of the
classical features
of uh quantum field theory
um so if you think about all of these
fields have got
a quantization com component but they
also have a classical component
electromagnetism being the simplest
example of that but there is a
effectively a classical component of
these other things and
stephen has shown that you can use
very simple computational systems
like cellular automata or other simple
things
that will have
many of the same
symmetries as
these more complicated theories
now there's two ways to view that one
way to view that
is to say yes that's great but
now tie them into a real quantum theory
and stephen would i think be the first
to say well
that's hard he hasn't quite done that
yet but he has done this intriguing
first part um
my friend peter has in a different way
done that first part
computation as well or completely
different is it also computational this
is much more about traditional
very very obtuse mathematics
um
the
and so maybe there is an approach like
that will work
but maybe not
so you're agnostic you don't have a
preference to which one of these
theories
as being the ultimate
i mean part of the tragedy
of super symmetry is that hunches
based on a mathematical idea
for the first time didn't work
right makes you pessimistic and so once
that's occurred
then you say and and man that one had
all the iq in the world
trying to desperately resuscitate it and
revive it and make it work
and yet it doesn't seem to be the way
nature operates
um at the same time
i have a basic faith in the
idea of physics which is
that we can figure out how the universe
works
and if you think about what we've
achieved so far
general relativity quantum field theory
um
boy oh boy we have understood
the universe around us uh
vastly better than in some sense we have
any right to
and um
you know whether you think that's luck
or
that's because there's some metric that
the simplest things actually work
or i mean you can go all
round and round on that um
you know the the counter example of
simple things
working out simply is number theory
where you know i can explain to a child
in a few minutes what integers are
and uh you can easily show
how factoring works and multiplication
works
and then you can state something like
the goldbach goldbox conjecture
and we have no clue how to prove it even
though it's obviously true
for any example you try
and that's an extraordinarily simple
system
so maybe it's that our idea of
simplicity isn't right
um anyway hey i still think it's worth
people trying to figure out the
fundamental laws
and it's well worth it but
we have gone through a very difficult
period in that
what do you mean when you say that our
idea of simplicity may be wrong what
could it be first of all what is it and
then what we are highly biased
towards things which we can explain with
simple continuum
model stuff
um so uh
the newton's great invention was the
calculus which was to say okay let's
reason about a continuum
of things starting off with the fact
well guys that we only have 10 fingers
and they're kind of discreet
it looks like you almost have nine yeah
i
cut myself in the kitchen
so just as an aside i would always say
when i learned about modernist cuisine i
would always joke to people and say yeah
he's a scientist and he's using his
physics background and his lab
to transform food it's essentially like
laser cooking a chicken to perfection
and then i always said that laser
cooking chicken but then i thought well
i don't see anything that you do as a
laser cooking then i thought well maybe
you do maybe i should ask you
is there anything uh sure you do
approximate something like a laser
cooking
oh sure um we uh
well there's lots of things where you
cook with light
so a neapolitan pizza is cooked with
light
um uh broiling is about cooking with
light it's all about infrared light
but for lasers specifically uh we've
done a bunch of
stuff that i think is cool i'm not sure
it's very fundamental
uh using laser cutters or leaves or
engravers
to do cool things you know we could etch
your face
on a piece of meat or on a slice of
bread because
it looks just like you um
or cut impossibly complicated
uh or otherwise impossibly complicated
patterns
out of a layer of sugar it sounds more
like presentation then
well for a laser cutter yes um lasers
by themselves uh
don't do a lot of things that we
would want to do with cooking
right i mean we're just we would rather
cook with a broad source
and continuous source of infrared than a
pulsed laser that would either burn a
hole
or be too diffuse so
in general lasers uh
are not the be-all and end-all um
but they're useful for some things
that's another reason why i wanted you
as an uncle
because i love food tremendously
and when i read that you made the
perfect fry with bathing it and
ultrasonic oil
is that correct yeah i'm like man i wish
i knew this guy because just so you know
before each interview
i fast so right now i'm at a a 48 hour
fast
and one of the reasons is because i try
to research as much as possible about
the interviewee
and one of the ways that i productively
do that is just by not eating so i can
just focus on work
until i sleep okay but another reason is
because i'm so
avaricious that when i do eat i eat like
mad and then i have to just i'm like
okay i must fast now
glad for this to end is what you just
told me
yeah okay so going back going back to
news
is we've had a strong bias
in physics for things that
can be solved by simple equations
ideally linear if they're non-linear
well not
too non-linear
and uh
and that's worked super well for lots of
things but
uh you know the the discoveries that
people had of
uh chaos and dynamical systems
and more generally fractals
out in whether there's fractals in the
real world or fractals
in solutions of equations are such that
the
uh the parts of the world that can be
totally modeled by very simple
models might be quite limited and we
might have already
slipped them all up you have like we
mentioned we have variegated fields that
you're pretty much an expert in
how practically speaking do you do the
research when you're interested in
let's say some new field field x what do
you start out with do you
interview do you call experts do you
just go on wikipedia do you go on google
scholar
what does the journey from knowing
nothing to becoming
moderately ensconced in it to becoming
an expert in it look like
well it's got all those steps um you
know you
first i try to read as much as i can
about it
um often that means i will buy
books on amazon as the first step do you
mind taking us through a specific
example you can pick photography you can
pick paleontology asteroids
um well sure i'll pick out let me start
with asteroids with asteroids
some people came to me with
actually a request to donate money to a
project
to build a satellite to go look at
asteroids
and we spent some time discussing the
physics of it and i wasn't very
satisfied and so they sent me
a white paper about
this and then i was really dissatisfied
because i just figured this has to be
wrong
and so i reached out to some folks and i
got some data
and it took me a few months
but i showed there's a whole bunch of
stuff that was
wrong with their approach you wrote a
100
page paper well i've had a couple of
them
actually so i don't know if the first
one was 100 it might have been
i've written a bunch of papers on it and
along the way yes i contacted
uh experts
contacting experts is
always tricky because
there are
experts are busy people and if you
contact them and say hi i'm some guy
you've never heard of
and i have got a question about x
um you better make sure that question is
a sensible question otherwise they're
just never going to respond to you
right um or they'll respond and say oh
that's nice kid
you know clearly you don't understand a
thing
and it's both a very natural human
response to being busy and to
you know not wasting your time on
crack pots and of the things on the
other hand
science isn't about that
but usually you can find some scientist
who
is willing to answer some questions if
you've got good questions about their
work
yeah uh and i love google scholar
i use google scholar not every day but
certainly every week
i'm looking something up and that's
useful because you can
get an idea of what the world thinks
and for a lot of um a lot of stuff
it's way more current than you would
find in textbooks
now it's i mean
typically a physics paper doesn't use
mathematics that isn't in a textbook
it might use physics it's not a textbook
but not mathematics that's not in the
text that's correct
right right right right um uh and so
sometimes you have to go to the math
literature
then to find new math for things and
that
uh going
in a field to the literature is both
super important
but it's also a little challenging for
an outsider because
people will have their own
a field will develop its own vocabulary
its own things that are sort of
obviously everyone knows x
versus no they they don't know x
um but
in general i have found that there are
enough scientists enough experts who
uh i can talk to who
will help me
guide me in the right way um
sometimes join on as collaborators
um or be good at critiquing things
mm-hmm and so away you go from there
um now in the case of asteroids
the buy every book on amazon
that's on asteroids is pretty easy
there's not very many
but in that case well then you also need
to make sure you that you've got
everything understood about
radiative heat transfer and conductive
heat transfer
and the mechanics
of the engineering aspects of
uh telescopes and optical aspects and ir
telescopes in particular
and
you know eventually draws in a lot of
stuff so it doesn't seem like you're
going completely out of field because
when you mention
telescopes and conductive heat it sounds
like that's building on some of your
previous knowledge
is there an example of where you've gone
completely out of left field i don't
recall what the saying is um
well depends what you mean by completely
okay how about this how about this let's
take why don't you take me through your
how you would sort out this problem
let's say there is the
issue of when do we go back to
quote-unquote normal
from kovid okay so there are quite a few
variables to think about
obviously there's politics as well but
let's say okay
well what's the infection rate and how
effective are
vaccines how effective are the masks and
so so how would you go about
solving the problem obviously we
mentioned you mentioned it doesn't just
depend on you but how would you go about
thinking about it i have
spent a lot of time working on
um computer models of infectious disease
so i'm very familiar with the state of
the art there in fact my company
uh created a whole unit of the company
called the
institute for disease modeling so in
that case i know
all about yet but
you don't need to have the details
to get the big picture
okay so the big picture on kovid
is very simple that
right now most people don't have it
okay which means most people are
vulnerable
and by most it's like 80 percent 85
percent
most places
well if you have 85 vulnerable you will
have another wave
okay unless you're extraordinarily lucky
and you're able to
plug every gap and do every other thing
but
that's that's an extraordinarily special
state of affairs
now the problem with diseases is they
grow
exponentially you know
if you get sick you can infect some
number of people
there's practical limits on how many you
can in
fact but no conceptual limit
well each of those can go out and do a
whole bunch of people and each of those
can do
and so it grows exponentially and
to get rid of a disease you have to make
sure that its
growth factor is negative so it dies
exponentially
but there's a tremendous
amount of evidence that most countries
in the world
are unable to have
a locks down enough society
for that to occur
so it was
it's a little annoying to me when you
see people
do a very normal human thing which is to
criticize folks that did it poorly
but in fact it's extremely hard
to do your reopening right
this oh my god we're shocked there's a
second wave
hello of course there was going to be a
second wave oh my god there's a new
strain
well you're lucky it took this long
viruses particularly rna viruses
are messy replicators they mutate like
crazy
so we have been lucky that covet
hasn't mutated more than it does
right right right and okay china
maybe south korea you can say there's
a couple people that you know did it
right
most other places a lot of other places
for a while thought oh we did it right
look at us we have low rates
and then they got another wave as they
were
going to get the other wave okay um
that's the other thing that is hard for
people to accept about something that's
so
important is that luck makes
a lot of difference
okay so we know about a variety of super
spreader events
um early in the epidemic there was some
birthday party in connecticut i think
that
30 or 40 people got infected and went
all over the place even in different
countries
and okay
that specific thing is bad luck
you couldn't have predicted up front
this will happen in
connecticut um
you could predict that it'll happen
somewhere
and there were places who for a variety
of reasons
have been lucky
and yet they pat themselves in their
back and they go yeah that's because we
were so damn smart
and there were places that were unlucky
now they were unlucky
and they weren't doing a perfect job but
if you look back and say how many
countries did a perfect job of this
um we can't really tell
until it's in retrospect but china has
done a very good job of containment
saying arguably south korea has
and i'm sure you could come up with a
few other also rams and
and others um
but it's uh
you know italy was an interesting
example italy
the worst part of the first wave of the
epidemic
was all in the north of italy
which is not what most people would
guess
because the health care system it's
widely believed
in italy and elsewhere that the health
care system
in the south is not as good
and that's a quantifiable thing it's
number of hospital beds and so on and so
forth
um so oddly
italy got sickest where their healthcare
was the strongest
now in a way that's really good because
at least they had some hope
and you're saying that's based on luck
in that example
well it's it's probably based
on the other thing the north is good
is known for which is the north of italy
is the industrial part of italy and they
have
the largest exports
and it's very likely that it was
people um in china on business
that brought it back to the rokkovic
back to
uh to the north of italy and
then from italy to new york because the
current um understanding is that the new
york epidemic
really was gotten from western europe
and italy in particular um
unlike in seattle where it was directly
uh directly people from china
so you know it i wouldn't you might not
say it was
luck pure luck because there might be a
factor like oh if you have
lots of industry in that industry
manufactures things in china
you're going to have a lot of engineers
and product managers and other people
going back and forth
so maybe calling that luck is too strong
a word
but it's not got anything to do with
your
medical system it's not got anything to
do with your hygiene it's
nothing to do with with that what about
government
well government certainly
you can find lots of instances where
the governments have done a
better job or a worse job
nathan you're in charge of the us right
now okay it's not guidance
you're in charge and my country canada
so what do you advise
canada and the us to do
well i really want to take more snow
off like pictures and i can't go to here
i doubt i'll be allowed to go this
winter so that pisses me off
but uh well the
only way all of the
kinds of shutdowns and things we've done
up to this point
have mostly been uh
it was a fascinating question that would
require lots of detail analysis to say
was it worth it
there certainly is a point of view that
says
if you could have walked the talk
and really buckled down like the chinese
did great
but if you can't do that doing a
half-assed job is probably
worse than doing nothing interesting or
it it gives you a double dose of bad
things
wait why is it worse because of its
effect on the economy huge effect on the
economy
and the huge effect of the economy also
affects health outcomes in people's
lives
so you can't really separate the two
super cleanly you can it
you know because i hear some people say
yeah you're prioritizing the economy
over people's lives but what you're
saying is that they're inextricably
linked
many parts of the world they are
uh and it
it's a it's an interesting question that
we'll have to ask
answer after the fact would we have been
better off
doing a simpler protocol
but really meaning it
like okay you are arrested or
i don't want to say shot on site but you
don't want to say it
tased on sight if you don't ask
but don't go through a whole bunch of
the other
silly things and you know here in
washington state
we had a i think a very well-meaning
government but you have the problem that
policymakers don't really know what to
do
because they haven't been in this
situation before
epidemiologists
have not always given great advice or
they have allowed themselves to be
talked down
in weird ways so for example when the
thing first came out
oh we're going to ban all meetings of
more than 100 people
oh wait wait did i say 100 i meant 10.
oh did i say 10 i meant
[ __ ] about somebody
with lots of well-meaning intentions
saying oh wait do we really have to
scrap
you know groups of 10 people and the
answer
epidemiologically was always two
don't allow two if everyone's alone
they can't transmit and then okay people
are gonna live with their families and
we're not to fix that
so don't expand it that was the right
answer
but you go through this thing of
saying something and changing it and
changing it and each one of those things
was a damn lie
the you go through another thing where
people and they're lying because
they don't feel like people will listen
if you say keep your social circle to
two
or because of some other reason i think
it sounded too
well there's lots of reasons and i
there's a lot of people say oh you're
overreacting you're overreacting you're
overreacting
also i heard in the beginning that who
said that masks were counter effective
well so
yes this was a great example
of well-meaning people
saying [ __ ] that was wrong
and you could eat in some cases
they couldn't help saying things are
wrong because we didn't know
but in in that case the mask thing was
horrifically stupid they had people
saying
literally oh it doesn't matter because
viruses are so tiny they'll go through
any
hole but you're not spewing pure viruses
so who the [ __ ] thought that was a good
thing you're
spitting okay and
if you have if you wear one of those
face masks
plastic face mask wear one even just
around the house for a little bit
and see how filthy it gets near your
mouth it's gross
but you're spitting all the time that's
how we
speak i see i see then there was a whole
set of other
weird political in uh there's a point
where
uh in washington state it was okay
to go golfing but you couldn't go
fishing
well that was some political [ __ ]
i'm sorry
there was no science that says
oh there's this then you also have
the scientists i have to say are also at
fault
because
there wasn't enough thinking about okay
is something worth doing at the level
we could actually do it
right so if we it's clearly the case
that if the us and canada could have
done
what china did it would be way better
for both the uh economy
and for the number of people killed
okay the the us has vastly more people
killed for for our size than china
but the fact is we couldn't do that
and given that you can't do it
and even you could argue well we didn't
know how incompetent we were up front
maybe
but i mean you say we didn't have enough
data about the virus or the people
involved in policymaking were
incompetent
well no but look you're never going to
get 100 compliance in anything
right like we all have laws about
speeding
yet virtually everyone who's ever driven
a car
has broken one of those laws at some
point in time it's
almost none of us get caught right
and we tr we use those laws to try to
get
the average speed right right
but if we had something that depended
critically on us following traffic laws
we would be [ __ ] right because we
cannot
bring ourselves to obey traffic laws
it's just a damn fact i you can
maybe someone could come up with some
way to make that occur but we
so china was able to go do it south
korea seems to be able to do it and
they're
a much more free society than china
um they still have a right sorry to
interrupt was china able to quote
unquote do it because they have a larger
enforcement mechanism such as they will
shoot you or they will tase you in your
previous example
or is it something else well
or the obedience of the population well
how do you separate those right i mean
the the way we have a law-abiding
society is through a combination
of catching the people who break the
laws
but mostly providing an incentive to
everyone else to follow them
right so uh
who is it because the chinese were
conditioned
to do what they're told or because the
threat there was threat of punishment
but wasn't that thriller
i mean i don't know you didn't separate
those two things
there was a uh
i can't totally remember the name of the
movie but it was a
sort of a comedic western movie where
this guy is given the
um is made sheriff he's given the star
of the former sheriff that is this big
dent unit
due to a bullet and the guy says well at
least this
um uh at least this star
was badge saved my predecessor
and guy giving it to him says well it
would have if it wasn't for all the
other bullets
right i mean it if you
if you sent the police out or you sent
the soldiers out with
something the size of my cell phone that
was completely bulletproof
it wouldn't be worth doing even if it
was perfect
where it was yeah there's too many other
holes
in the armor it's pointless
it's not worth anything it's true and
i i think that that is what
occurred in the covet response
of most of the countries in the world
they either enacted half
steps that could never could have worked
or they enacted ones that should have
worked
but they couldn't walk the talk they
couldn't actually
have enough compliance or
they waited until it was too late to do
that and exactly
and you probably come up with five other
reasons so i don't claim i know
all of the exact mistakes yeah
but it's when you have an exponentially
growing
thing it requires a
fanatical approach to try
to eliminate the disease
and we know that that's true from cases
where they eliminated
a malaria within a region we've never
done it for the whole earth
but we've done it in regions we know
that that was the case
with smallpox
but in smallpox we had a vaccine
so anyway it was very clear to me early
on
that we're just basically [ __ ] until
we get a vaccine
and it is worth going through
the various things some certainly it's
worth wearing masks
i believe that all along the current
belief is it's true
but we went through a phase of denying
that it was good for masks
or saying oh masks aren't good for you
they're just good for everyone else
now what about that is there any truth
to that
that's not what the latest research
shows
because fundamentally why do i never
sorry your spit and you don't want to
breathe my spit
yep and the whole point of these masks
is to reduce the amount of spit transfer
now it's not cutting it to zero
but we're reducing it and statistically
that means that there are people who
if in fact you were you know
locked in an elevator with someone for
48 hours
you know unless you had scuba tanks with
separate air systems
i don't know how you're going to avoid
some contagion
but for a lot of things
the mass would have worked but it also
undermined mask making you have people
think
it'd be much better from a compliance
perspective to tell people
oh this is all for you buddy
do it for yourself if your friends
don't want to do it fine you can cry at
their funeral
present the other way around
[Music]
so anyway uh i think that
the vaccine is the only thing that
given our general lack
of ability to control it with lockdowns
and
mask wearing and all the other things
we've tried in canada
and the us and all of europe and
essentially every other country except
china nobody's gotten
and south korea south korea nobody has
gotten a line on this so
obviously it's the vaccine that's our
next hope
you mentioned south korea but they don't
have the same authoritarian government
as china so
what was the deciding factor there
well um
i don't know uh
i i have friends who are korean or of
korean
background who would say oh actually
it may not be as authoritarian
but koreans have a very strong
sense of community and being gung-ho
interesting and cultural difference and
that there was a cultural difference
that they were more likely to follow
the rules now they also tested up the
wazoo
we didn't do [ __ ] for testing here yeah
and still barely don't
well how the hell are you going to stop
this exponential spread thing
if you can't identify who the hell has
it
anyway so this stage our only hope is
the vaccine
and we have to get it rolled out to
essentially everybody as soon as
possible now
there's a word that's been bandied
about called herd immunity
and herd immunity is a real feature of a
mathematical model of a disease
which basically states
if enough people get it
and your contact rate is low enough
then it's hard for the disease to spread
because if you have it but almost
everyone you run into
is immune then
you will resolve as doctors say that
means
either get better or die you will
resolve
and or at least stop being stop
transmitting
before you reach a vulnerable person
it's one of the ways to think about an
infectious disease
so you mean to say in hurt immunity that
if enough healthy people get it so that
they survive and then they become immune
to it
well you need to have immune people
okay now the through vaccination right
here of getting effect
of this well there's two ways there's
recovered people because for almost
every disease in the world infectious
disease
i should say you get some amount of
immunity
after you've had it um
malaria has the least immunity
after you get it but you still have some
or you don't get it as strongly or
there's a variety of other
things so basically
once you have society either recover
from that
or get vaccinated then you can stop it
but people
started talking about herd immunity when
five percent of the country
was infected or two percent was infected
and that was just absurd
and it was somebody working really hard
to try to find hope and say well maybe
maybe maybe we could
it's like be serious in
most any model you don't get to hurt
immunity until you get
well over half and usually it's more
like
three quarters so in
the stage when three quarters of the
population
have been rendered immune
then you can start to talk about her
immunity
and i say start because
the way you typically model diseases
is as if every one of us
might have some random possibility of
meeting some
other one of us any fine day
that's how the world works okay covid
was devastating
around the world what it got into
assisted living centers
and nursing homes because you're a set
of people that can't get away
and they see the same people every day
and you have caregivers that work at
more than one facility
doctors nurses other caregivers
so once coveted got
into an assisted living center
it was going to explode and and no
you know if if you had the last people
on earth to be vaccinated
we're all in the same nursing home
there's no herd immunity that's going to
save them if
covet lands there they're all going to
get it or a large fraction we'll get it
and die and
it'll be terrible yeah so uh
the
the actual number of people that we need
to achieve some slowing of infection
due to inoculation we don't know
but it depends on the circles that
people move in
you know if if in fact
you had kids that go to a particular
school
if covet gets to one of the parents and
then gets to the kids and then they
spread the at school
then you have a much tighter connection
to the other parents in that school
than you might have to some other group
of folks on the other side of town like
maybe a nursing home
right okay on the other hand once it
gets to the nursing home the nursing
home at
home has very strong connectivity to
each other
so it's a it's a complicated thing now
um
israel is doing a great job of giving
people injections
um of the people that are in their
priority groups for the first wave
in like the first week they've done a
third of them
okay it's a smaller country it doesn't
have a problem
that canada and united states both have
of a huge rural population
but still our cities aren't doing that
well
right and
that you know we have
we have somehow failed
we have the weird situation that we
panic enough to do some things like
close the borders you know close all
restaurants close this
but we don't seem to be panic enough to
say
okay this is a [ __ ] public health
emergency
we're calling out the national guard
we're putting people
or just put them in every damn walgreens
and cvs
or there's a hundred ways you could roll
out a vaccine
yeah way more effectively but instead
it's sort of like oh
yeah each state will decide and if the
state does a good job well that's good
if they do a bad job well those people
are a little [ __ ]
okay i don't want to keep talking about
covid i wanted to ask you some physics
questions but
i don't get to speak to someone who
studies infectious diseases much
and i haven't been keeping up with the
covid news and i hear that some people
say colvit isn't much
more dangerous than the flu so first of
all i want to know what do you say to
that and then second
what is the deal with this new strain is
it more
viral is it more potent in some way
so
well in both cases the world doesn't
know that much but here's the deal
there is we have a very strange
situation in our lives in general
where we get used to old risks and we
worry endlessly about new risks
so yeah influenza killed
you know hundreds of millions of people
in
1918. since 1918
every year it's killed a shitload of
people
now why are we okay with that well we're
okay with that because we tried as hard
as we could
to make vaccines we
did come up with vaccine that usually in
most
years sort of kind of helps
but it's also true that the number of
people who have died in the annual
um flu epidemic from say 1918
to today 100 years worth that's about
the same as died in 1918.
now you have a new thing like covid
and covid i should say in 1918 it had a
very weird pattern
of mortality
so it was terrible on 18 to 24
year old men and
yet it was very uh few fatalities and
little infectiousness in
people i think at over the age of 65 or
60 something like that
and it's believed the reason why is that
there was another flu epidemic
not as severe that was
like 50 years earlier
and so the people who got that influenza
were pretty much spared the new one
interesting
um anyway
even if it's quote only as bad as
it's a few percent death risk
for many parts of the population but
i'll just take me
i'm 61 so i'm over 60.
um i've had some uh
respiratory infections in the past i
like that
difficult number theory probably just
said i'm 61 so i'm over 60.
yeah it's one of those go back
conjecture problems well but that's one
of the thresholds
and i'm not over 65 where it gets even
worse
but i also have had a bunch of sinus
infections
chronically i'm arguably high risk
and then oh besides it killing you it
can also
put you in a in a permanent brain
fog there's a whole bunch of evidence
for that
it can take away your sense of taste now
that would [ __ ] up my
cookbook career if i couldn't taste
anything yeah for sure
so and it it will kill
lots and lots of people and it is a
because it's a new thing
we arguably should do everything we can
within reason
to stop it and saying oh it's just as
bad as the other stuff
is like well yeah but you don't want to
multiply that by
something i mean car deaths
are horrendous in the united states and
in canada and all over the world
um there are many more people
killed uh by cars in the united states
than there are by people
okay the it's like twice the murder rate
and our murder rate is way too high for
a developed country it's a
it's a shame it should be much lower um
well if you if you introduced a new
thing as an oh but it's just as
it's only as bad as cars well cars all
over again
takes a large mortality factor and
doubles down
you don't want to do that and is it only
as bad as the flu or is it more
viral is it more spreadable
well it turns out people don't really
know
both sides of that equation we certainly
know
that it is got uh
the mortality in some
age groups appears to be
way worse than we would than you'd say
for a typical
annual flu that it's more like the
epidemic flu of 1918
but then somebody else says but oh do we
really know how many people
have had it
and the answer is we don't
so there are people who are
living in close proximity with others
who had it
who didn't seem to get it
now did those people get it and repel it
and beat it
did they have some pre-existing
immunity there's a thought that there
are two coronaviruses
that are implicated in the common cold
mainly maybe if you had a cold last year
and it was one of those coronary viruses
maybe you're immune to it
we don't know now
it was weird in the uh
1918 flu that it mostly
killed young adults um
this one is weird in that it doesn't
seem to
kill young children it can
kill young children it's not zero
but the mortality rate is way way lower
now that's a it's a little surprising
because
very small children don't have a
developed immune system
number one number two it's
just usually it's a new disease
hits the very old and the very young and
it's the people in the middle that are
okay this one's not like that
it's the sums it's the very
old and the middle part of
the the stack and older that uh
that seem to be most at risk but a lot
of this
we don't know because it would require
a level of research that either
is difficult to do or hasn't been done
yet
um now with regard to the new strain
yeah well the new strain
appears to be this is a kind of the same
thing you
it's viruses are messy when they
um replicate you
almost always see some replication
errors
and that allows for example the
conclusion
that the seattle epidemic started with
people from china
whereas the european the new york
epidemic started with people from
europe that conclusion is precisely
because
the strains are always mutating a little
bit
and the first new york strains were more
similar
to the western european ones than to the
chinese ones
are you okay do you have one of them
i every year i get this allergic cough
but he does have everyone around me
thinking oh my god this is it
um he's in the final death of causing
fear to all your loved ones
um so uh anyway
this strain has been or some strain that
appears
to have popped up from nowhere
in the uk and also
in south africa and it's been found
all over the world now yeah
it's definitely a new strain by itself
that's not a big
surprise it might be more
infectious or more transmissible
that does occur with viruses we don't
know right now
i don't think there is enough there's so
many people that have said yes and
people who have said no
and a
out of an abundance of caution we have
to act
like oh it's it's yes
at the same time it's probably already
everywhere so
locking the doors probably doesn't do
that much
what it really ought to do is make you
want to get the vaccine out there
right wait sorry and this vaccine would
also
prevent the new strain from infecting
you well we don't
actually know that either see here's one
of the problems
in physics we are able to use
abstractions to
say here's a very general theory and we
can calculate it in a very simplified
situation but it also works in a more
complicated one
so for example we say conservation of
mass
conservation of momentum conservation of
energy
well you can use those principles
in lots of a very com otherwise
complicated circumstances
the problem here is the effect that a
vaccine has we know in theory what a
vaccine does
is it stimulates your immune system
to be on the lookout for this pathogen
and that allows your immune system to
mount a response
and overwhelm the pathogen vastly sooner
than it would otherwise um
but we don't know exactly whether
this is going to work with the others
because we haven't tested it
now this is one where if they have
enough
vaccination going on and enough
transmission of this new strain
they'll be able to figure this one out
relatively quickly
and my bet would be it does
but it's a bat and you know in the case
of flow
uh flu famously mutates enough that
every year we need a different vaccine
now because that's true for flu
you get this whole bunch of silly things
statements by scientists
where you know early in the epidemic
they'll say oh it'll all go away in the
summer
because it's a seasonal thing just like
flu
and people would say scientists would
say this to me he said what do you want
drugs
there's no evidence of that you're
hoping it's true
oh there's you but most most respiratory
viruses are and i said
what do you mean by most once you
subtract out flu
we really don't know squat about about
the cold
well common colds do propagate during
the summer
and in fact there's a fascinating thing
that no one knows why
we seem to associate colds more with the
winter
mm-hmm i see okay also
even though flu is seasonal no one knows
why
cold is not seasonal then or is it only
somewhat seasonal i don't believe that
the common well the common goals is
certainly not entirely seasonal
the um annual epidemic of influenza is
strongly seasonal
so if you take 50 years of data between
france united states this is what i
happen to know the statistics
the day on which the peak epidemic
occurs
as recorded by say number of hospital
admissions or
pick pick your metric
it's only a few days different every
year in france in the united states
now that means it's got to have some
very powerful
synchronizing feature
well that so obviously we figured that
out right
we haven't there's multiple theories
the theories of course contradict each
other and the theories also
frankly contradict common sense mostly
as far as i know one of the theories is
that in the cold we congregate more such
as in buses
so what about that common cold there's
that
uh-huh and there's that's certainly
this is one of the great questions
that is part of what rudyard kipling
would call a just so
story he had these just those stories
how the leopard got its spots and
they're sort of little fables for
children
yes it's true that we congregate in we
ride the bus more whereas we might walk
or ride bicycles
right um
is that why though
excuse me what timing huh yeah exactly
yeah give me one minute i'll be right
back yeah sure
you know the the number of things we
don't know is
frighteningly large um
but at the moment i think look our best
bet is the vaccines
and let's hope that the vaccines
do provide protection against this other
strain
um and whatever
one thing that's terrible about having a
large epidemic
is that in a very crude way
the size of the epidemic
determines the rate of evolution of the
virus
because every time he gets transmitted
to a new person you're running a new
evolutionary experiment and you could
have new mutations
that's why you're surprised that there's
only one new strain well
there isn't one there's hundreds of
strains
but they're little teeny teeny
differences i think this is one that
seems to be a larger macro difference
okay okay let's get back to some of your
asteroid research i remember you said
that in i believe it was
nasa's data they analyzed some of the
asteroids as
circular i mean sorry spherical when
when they're oblong when they're
elongated
please let me know if you recall what
i'm saying and but to me and to
virtually anyone listening that seems
like an
obvious mistake so why would these
experts model them spherically just
because it's easy
well
the it's true that the model that they
used
is a model which assumes that the
asteroid is a sphere
now if you have enough measurements of
it
you can show that that's okay it'll
compensate
they typically didn't have enough
measurements of it
but these the using a spherical model is
not the worst thing they did
they also just made data up
and just just cheated
yeah when you say they made data up they
copied data is that what you mean when
you say they made them up
yeah so you're supposed to be deriving
the um diameter of these asteroids
and instead you know and
the ones the way you tell if you did a
good job is you have about a hundred
asteroids
that you know the diameter of from a
different method
so you say right the way i determine my
accuracy is i predict it over here and i
compare it
to the known results and my predictions
match then i pat myself in the back and
said
i did something that was accurate yeah
um these people just copied all the
answers
and the consequence of that is what well
it well it's deeply unethical
number one number two they did this and
then they claimed that they had the most
accurate
diameters and they criticized everyone
else who had done
other data sets in the past even though
they had no idea of what their accuracy
was
and because they took the only cases
that uh where we know the answer and
they copied those
you can't now tell what the accuracy of
any of their things are
so they built it on a shaky foundation
yeah and i
i think it was just a rush
to try to get their project done and
also to make their project look like it
was a success
and we're talking about nasa here we're
talking about jpl
the jet propulsion laboratory so it's
a laboratory managed by caltech but
it's effectively part of nasa and
and some of the scientists who were
involved in this weren't njpl there are
various universities and so
you know it's the kind of thing that if
you or i had done as an undergraduate
um and we've been found out we would
have been expelled
and you know we'd be talking about how
our lives took this big turn we couldn't
become physicists
we were expelled for cheating and
um but because nasa
is very influential and gives out lots
of money
other scientists really didn't want to
criticize it so it turned out
a bunch they needed someone like you
who's independent to say
yes that's right this was
you know people would sometimes ask me
why are you doing this and the answer is
because paradoxically i'm the only one
who could
this is interesting this brings me to a
larger a thought occurs to me how much
of
let's say problems in science in general
there's a variety i'm sure but i'm
thinking
specifically right now about theoretical
physics and string theory
but problems in general are due to the
dependence on
funding from a certain agency versus
someone like you who can be independent
and say well here's what i think
and i can stand up to you well i don't
think it's super
common um you know
the the string theory
is so complicated that generally it's
very hard to compute
any answer out of it
um that that's why uh
my friend peter named his blog
uh after a saying of wolf king paulies
who was a great uh german physicist
it's not even wrong
so it's wrong would be it makes a
prediction
and it doesn't match the world but in
most cases in string theory
it's so mathematically difficult to make
a actual prediction
from it that
you're not even at that level okay okay
now the ramifications of the asteroids
does it have something to do with the
threat of asteroids being
underdetermined
well yes it the threat
the size of the asteroids is important
for two reasons one is as a
part of understanding how the solar
system was built
asteroids are a very critical part of
that
um asteroids are a little bit
like the junk you see at a construction
site
if you go to construction site where
they're building a house you'll see
sawed off pieces of 2x4 and nails and
all this other stuff
and that's a great analogy by the way
this is the material that was left over
from building
the solar system and it never really got
into a planet
or another thing and so it's kind of the
drug left over but
it's super interesting to understand
that junk to understand the conditions
under which the solar
system formed the other reason is
practical that we want to know
the threat that asteroids pose um
they were kind of tough on the dinosaurs
right right
we now know and you were there at one of
the first lectures
where that was proposed yes yeah that's
pretty cool
yeah it was that was a great example of
a
theory coming from outside a field
um it that at first sounded totally
outlandish
but in fact has stood the test of time
so um there are a few people who still
say
there were other factors that were
important or even critical with the
dinosaurs
but the idea that mass extinctions
could be caused by an impact has now
been
traced to lots of other mass extinctions
not just
that one um
going back to the threat uh
yeah so it's very important to know for
the threat
particularly because the way some of
these
this asteroid work is funded is by
telling congress oh this is important
for the threat
yes you tell congress look this isn't
just
a bunch of scientists having fun with
the origin of the
uh solar system no no this might
tell you what thing is going to plunk
down in the middle of kansas next week
and so we really need to know it yeah
and it's compelling argument
so they have an incentive to overplay
the threat of asteroids or did you find
in your research that we're actually
underplaying it
well it's in
they're using that threat as a way to
ask for more funding and i say you
shouldn't give those people more funding
until they learn math or
and ethics uh so
um and that goes for both now there's
lots of other people at jpl that are
great
there's not everyone at jpl but there's
one group of jpl
there's one person but one professor at
ucla that
really screwed up um
and had a giant amount of arrogance
about that screw up and so didn't admit
it and has
fought it to the mail because they
thought you i recall that they put out
an article
oh yeah no they they did did a smear
campaign on me
trying to attack me um
they it's been very hard for me i have
published
several papers including one over 100
pages
but it's been much more difficult for me
to do that because
uh i'm the guy who's saying that
people in the field are totally wrong
and some people in the field agree with
me
but say well why don't you just like be
a little quieter about it
it's like no that's
unethical to be quieter about something
that's this bad
um are you driven by ethics or were you
always disagreeable and you'll point out
what's wrong when you see it
well
i certainly noticed that they had done
some things very seriously wrong
and initially it wasn't this copying
initially what i noticed is that they
didn't understand freshman physics
and they even the professor didn't
understand freshman physics
yep um
just no they is there something called
kirchhoff's law of radiation
it's in all early physics classes
it's part of understanding what's called
black body radiation which is
fundamental to all of the modeling they
do
they didn't understand it at all
um when you say they didn't understand
it do you mean to say that they didn't
incorporate it
okay they their approach to modeling
totally violates it
so they're they tried to apply
a method which violates physical law
which that's a bad thing to do
now it's a bad thing to do that most
people would generally ascribe to
ignorance
or maybe ignorance backed up with
arrogance
not ethics it was that
after you've i found the ethical things
that in some sense made it even worse
and the ethical things you're talking
about the copying of data okay
unethical things and uh
the science
exists because we trust it and we can
only trust it
if we're vigilant to it and
you could get lots of scientists to say
oh yes that's true
but the ones in general they don't apply
that
uniformly in this case the professor at
ucla
is kind of a loudmouth jerk who likes to
one-up people
and has a reputation for being really
smart
um which is weird because in all of his
interactions with me
he's nothing he says makes any sense at
all
but he says it are you able to say his
name abruptly
um
uh aggressively oh you don't understand
it because of this theory i'm not
throwing
that and it's only if you both know all
those theories and this you say wait a
minute
that is a bunch of [ __ ] this brings
me to a larger problem
that you mentioned with regard to kovit
and now nasa and
a general cultural movement to distrust
mainstream science
well here's what's interesting is that
there's seems to me
from the outside let's say i'm
investigating an issue like global
warming
now obviously some people say it exists
some people say it doesn't exist and you
have your
your own you you seem to know the answer
to that because you've investigated it
but to me from the outside okay how does
one
go about researching a contentious issue
when it seems like there are incentive
structures on each side to either say
that global warming exists or doesn't
exist
or whatever the issue whether it's
global warming or not given that as you
mentioned
sometimes these large institutions all
agree on a single
narrative and they might be colluding or
they might be just ignorant or whatever
it may be
so what what are we to do as individuals
just investigate on our own
hey i don't have a good answer for you
you know we
we have this situation
that for a variety of reasons
there are folks that don't want to take
the vaccine
because they don't trust some element
of this whole thing they either say i
don't trust
big drug companies or i don't trust that
we
develop this under record time why don't
they go back and do it more slowly
you don't [ __ ] people are dying that's
why um
and it turns out that the
the argument that they ought to be made
to them is very straightforward
which is current goals and speed you
will get
coven every one of us will
i'm not referring to coveting specific
i'm just well okay but here's the deal
every one of us will get it and for
almost every one of us
like probably every one of us getting
covered
has a higher risk threshold than the
worst vaccine anyone ever made in
history
so these vaccines actually seem like
they're the best vaccines anyone made in
history
as it turns out just out by accident but
even if it was the worst
give it a break this is like people
driving to the airport who are afraid
about
a plane crash because a plane they're
going to get on
but then driving the airport is vastly
more dangerous
i see okay now how you get people
to internalize those things and believe
them
i don't know it certainly doesn't help
that kovit has been politicized
and i mean that with both capital p
politics you know associated with
the the trump administration or the this
or that
but it also means small p politics like
oh let's say it's okay to golf but not
to go fishing
know these golf courses are going to be
really mad at us
it it and so you have a situation where
people also the scientists
have been groping their way
now the fact that they the they've
changed their minds
ought to make them more believable
if you say yep i had my mind made up
and nothing i can see will ever change
my mind
you should not trust that man because
you need to have someone who's
constantly weighing evidence
and new evidence of new things can
change your mind
but we've had the unfortunate situation
that
there are a lot of people who um
who don't believe and and will refuse
the vaccine
now the rude thing to say is that's just
evolution in action
those people will suffer a higher rate
of
uh consequences
from uh covet than from the vaccine and
to a certain percentage we can tolerate
that
in society um
i say a certain percentage because of
that herd immunity thing because you
don't have to get to every last
person however i think when it comes to
stuff
like the anti-vaxxers that don't want
their children
immunized yep
it is a real danger to other kids in the
school
and to below school-age
children of families that have someone
a kid in the school and so on and so
forth to have those kids not be
vaccinated
and it's really bad for them
so you know on one hand in a free
society you want
to allow people to have a certain set of
freedoms
on the other hand you don't typically
allow those
freedoms to allow a parent to kill a
child
for example which
that comes up in the cases where for
example they're refusing a medical
procedure
for religious grounds
and the united states canada as far as i
know
uh europe they say no at a certain
point the state will intervene and they
will try to
say the kids get saved because
we we do protect children even if their
parents aren't
just like we take children away from
people who are bad parents
so what do you do with people who are
passionately convinced about something
that is demonstrably wrong
well when that demonstrably wrong thing
has constant
he if it's a religious matter
i say leave it alone people can have
different ideas about religion
they can each say well my god is right
and that other guy's
is wrong about his god
let him but when it comes to things like
not taking a vaccine um
you know there will be a period this
spring where people start
needing to go back to work and we'll
have enough people vaccinated
and i think it's very reasonable to say
you shouldn't go back to work if you're
not vaccinated
or have proof that you had
coveted um but
that'll cause a whole bunch of people to
get all worked up and say oh it's civil
liberties and we have to allow people
that
when it comes to things that truly only
affect them
it's a very different issue than when it
affects others
let me restate the question a bit more
clearly some of the many of the audience
members almost all of them i think are
extremely extremely intelligent people
so for them
they're listening forget about covid
forget about covid like you mentioned
you're also extremely extremely
extremely bright and
probably if you didn't look into the
research on asteroids you would have
maybe you would have accepted what nasa
had said maybe you wouldn't have
regardless how do you sort out i was
going to say signal from the noise but
it's almost like signal from anti-signal
or from contrived signal when you do
like
what do you do as a as an intelligent
person do you just have to dive into the
field
do you just have to trust it because you
can't just doubt
everything you have to live your life
okay but
living in a society is something
that involves a lot of trust
right so it to live in a civil society
you have to have a certain degree of
trust that everyone else is going to
live up to their obligations
more or less and you know that if they
don't you have some recourse
you can call the police so you can
complain in some fashion
um but it yeah
you have to trust in the case of physics
you have to trust what
generations of physicists have produced
and that the scientific method and the
people looking at things and really
looking at things
and being critical of them including
publishing my papers things other stuff
is [ __ ]
that that process will get us to the
right answer
most of the time and i think most of the
time it does
you know there certainly are examples
of uh fields or
particularly politicized fields
that i think it is much more difficult
you know certainly global warming
has gotten that way it is a politicized
field in that lots of politicians
or people on the street will have
very strong opinions that have nothing
to do with actual
science they will have to do with
you know the consequences on that on
their industry or
their ideology or some other set
of stuff that makes it more difficult
you find the same thing is true with
nutrition
you know nutritional science
uh has unfortunately
failed us broadly
you know it went on a jihad against fat
we should get rid of fat which
everything be low fat
and during the decades that we went on
the low fat
uh approach yeah the
obesity rate has gone up the rate of
ingestion of
uh i mean all the bad things they said
would go down have gone up
right right and in that case it's
probably based on
just some fundamental bad work
in the 1950s and 60s that got propagated
um and the fact that
there are people who make their money
either as you know commercial food
sellers or sellers of junk foods and so
forth
or people who are health food advocates
on the other side
helps to politicize with a small pee
this issue right so we have this huge
movement uh against gluten
and there is no good science
in support of it there are
people who shouldn't eat gluten because
they have
a very sp specific thing but
the overwhelming majority don't well
well the the trend has become oh
read a couple of websites and then
self-diagnose that you need this
and then uh eat a whole a diet
that has all kinds of other [ __ ] in it
that is much less
tested than gluten one of the beautiful
aspects of your book modernist cuisine
when i first read it
and by the way i think i went to the u
of t library the first day that it
ordered it
because i was so excited to read it but
it was a huge book and i couldn't afford
it at the time
was in the first chapter i believe you
dispel some of the myths some
extremely ingrained myths so for example
with butter versus margarine and i
didn't know that at the time okay that
butter is much
healthier for you it seems to be
something that we all seem to take for
granted now but
for 50 years or so that wasn't the case
also
i think you mentioned that bacon has
olic acid is oleic acid or olic acid
compared to all much at a higher
percentage than all this one
thing where it got to be trendy for
people to say that
there were protective features in olive
oil
based on very skimpy amounts of studies
you know a huge problem with nutritional
epidemiology
is that it's extremely difficult and
expensive
to do the kind of study you need to do
where you study
people and outcomes over a 20 or 25 year
period
so instead people would fixate
on a proxy measurement so they said oh
cholesterol is bad for you
so we'll measure cholesterol if your
cholesterol goes up then we know that's
bad for you
well then it later turns out well
actually there's good cholesterol
there's bad cholesterol
and then it turns out oops dietary
cholesterol
probably has no factor at all
um just for the people listening that
means you can ingest cholesterol such as
an eggs and it doesn't raise your blood
cholesterol
well in particular there are
the the kind of cholesterol that you
would worry about
in a cardiac situation is manufactured
by your body
and so the dietary thing isn't
really a factor i see i see now that is
such
and of course when these things came out
did people come and say oh you know
something
we were wrong we [ __ ] up we were wrong
we're sorry nope
most of this so most people still think
cholesterol
is bad for you and your cholesterol
counts thing they kind of know there's a
good and a bad kind now
but the butter thing you mentioned
in one of the few really long term
really good stuff something called the
nurses study
over 25 years they awarded that now
they followed the health of 25 000
nurses
they found that the people who ate
margarine
had double the cardiac uh problem rate
and death rate
of people who ate butter which means
there's a whole lot of health food
advocates
that killed people straight up
they went out there recommending
margarine
margarine it turns out merger at the
time
was was what we now call a trans fat
but they had it so in their heads that
um
saturated fats were bad and this was a
polyunsaturated fat so it must be better
and that little surmise
was dead wrong in fact trans fats
actually are bad literally dead wrong
right literally dead wrong it literally
killed lots of people
um and so when you have situations like
that
or some of the other absurd things to
come
bring it back to gofet you know the
people taking your temperature
that was an absurd thing
telling people who have a fever to stay
inside
makes tons of sense yep
what's absurd about taking someone's
temperature as you enter a store let's
see
hood there's a set of things that you
often
find in
uh this sort of situation that i call
purification rituals
so lots of religions
have a thing on purification
that stuff gets to be dirty
in god's eyes somehow and then you have
to purify it with a ritual
and there's a controversial theory by
an anthropologist named robert uh
sapolsky
that says the reason religions
all have purification rituals is that
eventually
they get a priest who has ocd
and that priest's ocd winds up
being manifest in them writing lots of
purification rituals now i don't know if
that's really true
right i'm going to be talking to robert
at some point
i don't i have some issues with that but
we can talk about that after well it
the idea that you would empower
the nation's waitresses and sales clerks
to all go and take your temperature
and oh what are you supposed to do if
the person has the fever
are you in a hazmat suit when you're
doing this
uh no
and it's well-meaning
but it's something that i think if you
looked at the amount of effort
that it caused versus
the uh the you know
the cost benefit basically how much
heart would it cause for how much
benefit
so like at our company i said [ __ ]
we're not going to have some poor
employee
who has to go up and down a line and
do this and expose themselves they're
the ones that'll get it
yep why did we do that
yeah you know another thing is they said
oh you have to have everyone enter
in the same entrance so that you
can you know count them all and you can
know exactly how many people are in the
building
why well what if we have to contact
trace
and i said well we'll ask the people
i mean it turns out at my company and i
think
almost every company you don't act every
minute of the day
like you can't trust the people there
to do even the simplest thing
um you know if in fact they came into
the office on a particular day
well you'd know that regardless of which
entrance they came into because the
card key system does it so you can all
you can email everyone who's in the
building so if there was a contagion
event you would email them then you can
ask them
hey were you near george that day
because it turns out george came down
with coven
but there's always this oh let's lock
everything down
and
it would be a difficult calculation
to do but if you said okay what is
really better
picking some set of people to be the
poor
person at the door would be
with the temperature gun and
how many people did you really turn away
and therefore if you know how many you
turned away
what what did this really do for the
epidemic overall
now in a perfect world i don't doubt you
should stop those people from coming in
and in japan
when you go into customs man you're they
have all of these signs
and monitors up and it's zeroing in and
automatically taking your temperature
for everybody in the room and okay that
makes some sense
if you found somebody came coming in
with a horrible
fever you could then decide
to do something quarantine them for a
little bit
but of course what you can do with all
the people that happen to be standing
next to them
or run the flight with them or whatever
even then
it i don't think the japanese have fully
thought it through
because if that person really is
the um start of a terrible epidemic
because whenever you detected the fever
you'd have to like
stop the everything
you know have you know little tubes come
down from the ceiling and seal everyone
off separately it it would be really
very difficult
when i first heard about you i remember
you were talking about as could have
been a freakonomics you were talking
about a way of solving
global warming with geoengineering and i
remember being intrigued because you
said it requires something like a few
million dollars or maybe a few billion
but that's still relatively low
and you raise some balloons and you have
a tube that emits sulfur dioxide i
believe
okay that sounds like a an extremely
inventive and simple idea why
don't i hear much talk about
geoengineering solutions to the problem
of global warming
what are the problems with them in
general
oh let me explain where i'm coming from
because i see that we should get to zero
emissions
in carbon but then even if the carbon
that's in our atmosphere stays there
that's still going to cause a certain
amount of problems over time
which means that something else needs to
be done
anyway of course of course
it's is it political like what's going
on yes it's political
it's well first of all it's political
within the scientific community the
scientific community itself
has become very polarized
that the people who study global warming
uh got very
tight they kept saying oh this is a
problem
why look here thinking wow here's the
thing
if i show you this evidence society will
immediately start listening to us
and no matter what they showed society
didn't
listen to them well that's caused
a thing where
there are lots of scientists in
the field who are very leery
about publishing anything or doing any
research on global warming
because their fear their their
friends will chastise it as being some
form of accommodation to the other side
okay and what do you say other side
stupid what do you think
is stupid and it's counterproductive
well
then there's the there's a lot of
global warming activists or climate
activists
and they think that the global warming
problem is very much
like a children's book that i read as
a as a little kid it's called the little
engine that could
there's not this little end a little
steam engine
and it needs to take this
stuff over the mountain and all the big
engines are scared to do it
and the little engine says i'll try and
then it says i think i can i think i can
i think i can
well a lot of people in the
uh global warming world
are like that they think look we know
exactly what to do
we have the technology it's easy
we're just a bunch of
you know fat [ __ ] that are addicted to
our suvs
and is as soon as we just all do the
right thing
this will this problem will be solved
and and then if you come up with global
warming
then those very people will then
say you shut up
we're trying to convince society we're
probably we're trying to tell society
i think we can i think we can we'll try
to be positive here
and the minute you say you have a
different solution
it lets the air out of the balloon
we need to threaten these people that
there's no other way to save earth
otherwise they won't listen to us mm-hmm
so i say in response i say
okay show me how much progress we've
made
well we have made any progress
well okay suppose we did the full paris
accord
well everyone knows that is [ __ ]
and of course then i did the
calculations for myself
if there was no
more emission tomorrow we stopped it
which there's no way we can do
it right right right but the temperature
would continue to rise for about
100 years
then it would start to slowly decrease
individual model in 145
years the temperature would be less than
it is today
so now i ask you is the is global
warming
a serious problem or not
and it's very funny to me because
if you if you talk to people who deny
the existence of global warming
there's a set of people that say listen
to the science
but then if you say okay tell me a
credible plan
for actually getting to zero emissions
and not having a disaster
according to you well
they can't but they also don't want you
to let that cat out of the bag hey shut
up
we'll get we'll get some level of
compliance now and then we'll we'll get
a little more in the future
and if we like told people the truth the
the ones that are honest will say if we
told people the truth
they would be too um afraid
well that's [ __ ] and lying to people
just
doesn't help the situation that's why no
one has believed this
right so
anyway so to those people i say we'll
listen to the science
because the science is actually very
very clear
that we don't have any natural way
to take co2 out of the atmosphere
quickly
and the science is very clear that at
any point in time
we have another 100 years of warming
that's already baked in the cake
so if you think that 100 years of
warming
and sorry that 100 years how much of an
increment is it
a couple degrees and that's
significantly for sure because different
models will say different things but
okay it you'll get people to say we
can't
possibly allow another one more degrees
c
mm-hmm but it's going to happen
regardless that's three degrees c no
matter what
yes yes yes number one number two if you
think
it's bad if your proposition
is that three degrees c will
you know unleash hell on earth well
let's start working on it because it's
common no matter what
we do okay so this seems to me like
people who are on the side that say well
let's just get to zero emissions and
that should solve it that they don't
actually
care about the saving of the earth
because if they did they would pursue
some of the geoengineering solutions as
well
so what is it that they care about do
they just dislike capitalism they
dislike the fact that we in the west
okay there's definitely people like that
and then there's definitely people who
are not like that you know when
you to people who are true
environmentalists or conservationists
they'll say what you mean we can
actually avoid destroying earth
[ __ ] that's great tell me more
the people who are the ones that are
most against it
i think are the ones that view this
mostly as a political struggle
and as something of a struggle
of capitalism versus
something they don't really propose an
alternative right
right but uh for those people
they would say hey you capitalist greedy
bastards
sinned against the environment this is
your fire and brimstone just cause
and don't go telling people you can make
it better
i'm trying to make it better with more
inventions
but then i say look if are you saying
it's going to destroy the environment
well
why don't we try not to destroy it
but he's near that oh it's going to kill
millions of people how about this let's
try not to kill millions of people
why is that not a good idea
we don't know how bad global warming
will be
we have a bunch of models the models
predict
different amounts of temperature
increase in different time scales
at some point it'll be very bad
we don't know exactly which point and we
also don't know exactly which
point that temperature will occur
so if people say i don't want to start
doing geoengineering today
i say fine don't start it today but
let's research
the hell out of it nathan what in your
eyes are the most efficacious
geoengineering prospects
well currently the one i like best is
something that
that goes on the rubric of solar
radiation management this means
you reflect a tiny amount of light from
the sun
way in the upper atmosphere um way less
light than i mean you could never
visually determine
exactly exactly it's imperceptible but
it would be enough
to stop global warming and it would be
with sulfur dioxide or some other method
well then you can get in then you go
down into the weeds
of a hundred different engineering
trade-offs
and people should study all those
different trade-offs
um sulfur dioxide has the
advantage that we know it works because
volcanoes do it
and we know that although sulfur dioxide
is not something we want
enormous amounts of in our world
we know that we're tolerant the
environment is currently tolerant of
quite a bit that comes from volcanoes
and the extra amount we would need is a
very small fraction above
what's coming from volcanoes so
there's a plausible argument that it's
the safest
there's lots of people who immediately
try as
hard as they can to see a problem with
that
and hey fair enough they they should
do that research and publish those
papers but other people should also be
saying let's try to figure out how to
make this work
because current course and speed we're
not doing [ __ ]
for the problem
nathan thank you so much for being
extremely generous with your time
please hopefully you recover from your
your kovid i wrote down that
other they're classically trained chefs
like gordon ramsay and someone i watch
plenty of his shows and he says that the
most important
aspect of any recipe is the ingredients
being fresh
i always wondered is that true or is
there something else like can you take
unfresh ingredients from walmart let's
say and create a wonderful meal
with some of your technologies tell me
your position on cheese
exactly yeah right cheese is very old
milk
wine well that's kind of old spoiled
grape
um you know aged beef
uh so i agree
with uh him that you want high quality
ingredients high quality does not
mean necessarily mean that
it's all got to be absolutely fresh
there's enormous numbers of dishes made
with dried
pulses or beans or lentils or grains
and that stuff is dried and it doesn't
have to be fresh
so there are some foods where
the freshness of the ingredients is
absolutely paramount
there's other foods where aging the
ingredient
is absolutely paramount and most things
are somewhere in the middle
and it it's also
you know the a chef who is cooking for
other people
ought to do the best they can
but not every little restaurant
in the middle of the country can get
access
to diver caught scallops
and so then you have this dilemma does
that mean you
never serve scallops and some people
would say yes there was a scallops and
good for them but i think it's a little
bit elitist
to say oh no you can never serve a
frozen
piece of fish because you know the
fact is the middle of continents have a
very hard time getting fresh ocean fish
they can get it sometimes a huge expense
but is it always required
thank you thank you so much you gotta go
i appreciate your time man
thank you you're one of my idols have a
great one no i mean that man
i want to even ask you like how are the
pyramids made because i feel like you
have an answer for everything
and apparently there's a mystery there i
know actually a friend of mine has
figured that out
okay geologist friend of mine has really
figured out how they built the pyramids
you you can just reference the name so i
can search it unless you want to explain
it i know you gotta go
it's in a bunch of nova uh uh
videos um i'll email you the stuff
what's his name though i'm blanking on
it
okay i'll post the name all right man
there were a panoply of questions that i
had written down that i didn't get a
chance to
bring up during the interview but i
emailed him so here are two extra
questions
one i wanted to know what is his opinion
on the latest news regarding ufos and
even bob lazar
who claims to have worked on spacecraft
he said
i think it's arrogant to believe we are
the only intelligent beings in the
universe
that said i don't think that the hard
evidence for ufos is currently
sufficient to say that ufos are in fact
aliens visiting the planet the u in the
ufos is unidentified and that remains
the case
i don't know about mr lazar's claims so
i can't comment
okay the other question i had was about
consciousness do you think consciousness
emerges from a physical basis that is a
physical substrate like the materialists
might say
or not and why in other words what's
your opinion on the hard problem of
consciousness
nathan says our brains are physical so
yes i think that consciousness
originates in a physical organ
i think that a lot of consciousness
discussion goes away with
an obsession on human exceptionalism
animal experiments to show that a
number of species have a concept of self
have mirror neurons which model what
others think
and so forth while these traits may not
rise to the level of full human
consciousness
i think it's likely that they are
precursors
okay i hope you enjoyed this podcast if
you enjoyed it please consider donating
to
the patreon supporting this channel
because right now i'm pretty much doing
it pro bono
it takes up almost all of my time and it
would be great if i could
somehow manage to keep up the level of
sophistication detail and quality
thank you thank you so much